Islamophobes everywhere are moaning and
wailing because the new home secretary
of the United Kingdom is a devout
follower of the religion of peace and
tolerance. Shabbana Mahmood seen here
delighted after tens of thousands of
British girls lives were ruined by her
Pakistani cousins is now one of the most
powerful women in Europe and
Islamophobes are not happy about it.
Tommy posted, "Shabana Mahmood, who
swore her oath of parliamentary office
on the Quran, is to be Starmmer's new
home secretary. She will now be in
charge of immigration and the borders."
Here she is saying Islam to her is more
important than anything. Labor need
removed. Chris Rose complains. The UK
now has a home secretary who previously
encouraged mob rule after joining an
anti-Israel protest which forced shops
to close down. Shabbana Mahmood is
incompetent and dangerous. Aal Jacobi,
whose name sounds suspiciously Jewish,
laments. Breaking. Shabbana Mahmood has
become the UK home secretary. She is in
charge of immigration, visas, and
borders. Here she is at a rally calling
for a globalize the inifada. Rest in
peace, UK. Islamophobes are throwing
this tantrum just because Shabban
Mahmood, peace be upon her, loves her
religion. on faith itself um Islam my
own religion um
like a lot of practicing Muslims my
faith is the most important thing in my
life it is the absolute driver of
everything that I do um I feel a very
strong um calling of my own conscience
and my conscience calls me to God that
is how I know that I am a Muslim
>> now I'm just a silly American who's
absolutely thrilled that the founding
fathers of my country wanted to get as
far away from this British dumpster fire
as possible. So, I don't even know what
a home secretary is. Home secretary
sounds like someone taking notes and
scheduling appointments.
What is Shabban Mahmood actually in
charge of? Let's check Wikipedia.
Corresponding to what is generally known
as an interior minister in many other
countries, the home secretaries remmit
includes oversight of home officer
ministers, law enforcement in England
and Wales and UKwide elements of
policing that are not devolved. Matters
of national security and
counterterrorism,
matters of immigration and border
security, oversight of the security
service, MI5.
Sounds like she's in charge of pretty
much everything British people are
panicking about right now. Fortunately,
Home Secretary Mahmood has endorsed the
all party parliamentary group on British
Muslims definition of Islamophobia,
which runs as follows. Islamophobia is
rooted in racism and is a type of racism
that targets expressions of Muslimness
or perceived Muslimness.
Awesome. Islamophobia is a type of
racism that targets expressions of
Muslimness.
How does this work? Well, suppose a
British Muslim declares on YouTube that
once Western nations become Islamic
states, apostates will be publicly
executed. This isn't part of our
religion. There's a reason to it. Yeah.
There's a reason why there's a capital
punishment. Because people like you,
little weaklings who leave their
religion and cause uh corruption in the
land by spreading it, the capital
punishment in Islamic law would be
applied to you. We have no doubt and
we're proud of that. Yeah. Capital
punish will be applied in an Islamic
state.
>> His words here are an expression of
Muslimness because Muhammad commanded in
Sunnisai 4064 and many other passages,
whoever changes his religion, kill him.
So if a Muslim YouTuber says that once
Islam gets the political power,
ex-Muslims will be publicly executed and
you say, "No, that's bad." You're a
racist and the British government will
soon be storming your apartment in the
middle of the night and dragging you off
to jail. And for some reason,
Islamophobes are worried about this
bunch of racists. These racists are also
worried because when Shabbanak Mahmood
was sworn in as justice secretary, she
took her oath of office on the Quran, a
book that allows Muslims to break their
oaths whenever it's convenient. As we
read in surah 66:2,
Allah hath made lawful for you Muslims
absolution from your oaths. Islamophobes
are also throwing tantrums because the
Quran calls Jews, Christians, and other
non-Muslims the worst of creatures.
We're lower than pigs according to the
Quran. By contrast, Surah 3:1 says that
Muslims are the best of peoples ever
raised up for mankind.
The Quran says that Allah has no love
for non-Muslims. That's why Allah just
doesn't care what Pakistani Muslims do
to non-Muslim girls. The Quran defines
Muhammad's followers as people who are
severe against disbelievers and merciful
among themselves.
So, Islamophobes are posting a bunch of
the standard excuses for racism
targeting expressions of Muslimness.
But I'm not interested in any of that.
There's a much much bigger problem here.
What's the real problem? Well, no one
caught this. But by becoming home
secretary, Shabban Mahmood has just
doomed everyone in Great Britain to
charges of Islamophobia.
Everyone, Muslims and non-Muslims are
about to be classified as Islamophobes.
Everyone.
Every last person in Great Britain will
forever be an Islamophobe. All because
of Home Secretary Shabban Mahmood. And
I'll tell you why. In Sahil Bukari 7099,
Muhammad said, "Never will succeed such
a nation as makes a woman their ruler."
Women can't rule. According to Muhammad,
if a nation has a woman as its ruler,
that nation will fail.
Why? Because according to Muhammad, not
according to me, according to Muhammad,
women such as home secretary Shabbanak
Mahmood are intellectually deficient. In
Sahil Bkari 2658, Muhammad said, "Isn't
the witness of a woman equal to half of
that of a man?" The women said, "Yes."
He said, "This is because of the
deficiency of a woman's mind." So women
by nature have deficient minds. But
women aren't simply deficient in
intellect. They're also deficient in
religion. And they're the majority in
hell. Sah Muslim 241.
Oh women, give in charity and pray a
great deal for forgiveness, for I have
seen that you are the majority of the
people of the fire. A wise woman among
them said, "Why is it, oh messenger of
Allah, that we are the majority of the
people of the fire?" He said, "You curse
a great deal and are ungrateful to your
husbands. I have never seen anyone so
deficient in intellect and religion more
overwhelming to a man of wisdom and
reason than you."
My goodness, think about the awful
position that the UK is in because of
Home Secretary Shabban Mahmood.
Whatever happens while she's in office,
everyone's an Islamophobe. No matter
what you think about Shabban Mahmood,
you're an Islamophobe now. If you think
she does a terrible job as home
secretary, you're an Islamophobe because
you're a racist for thinking that a
Muslim woman is doing a terrible job.
Who are you? You're one of the worst of
creatures. She's one of the best of
peoples.
How dare you question anything she does?
If you think she does a bad job, you're
clearly just a racist and an
Islamophobe.
On the other hand, if you think she does
a great job as home secretary, you're an
Islamophobe because you're saying she's
smart and that the nation is succeeding
with her as a leader when Muhammad
clearly said that women are
intellectually deficient and that any
nation with a woman as a ruler will
fail. So if you think Shabbanak Mahmood
does an awful job as home secretary,
you're a racist, Islamophobic,
hate-mongering bigot because the only
basis for objecting to anything your
Muslim superiors do is Islamophobia.
And if you think she does an amazing job
as home secretary, you're an Islamophobe
for contradicting Muhammad's teachings
about women when we all know that only
racists and Islamophobes contradict
Muhammad's teachings. Either way, you're
a racist and an Islamophobe, which means
that the United Kingdom is now the most
racist, most Islamophobic nation on the
planet.
Oh, the irony. I spent the past 20 years
of my life warning the people of the
United Kingdom about what they were
dealing with. And they spent the past 20
years of their lives calling people like
me racists and Islamophobes.
And now they're all racists and
Islamophobes. Every single one of them.
I hope they're starting to understand
why we dumped their disgusting tea into
Boston Harbor.
You
[Music]
just fine on me. You
just fine on me. This is a power
religion. There's a reason to it. Yeah.
Yeah. Here.